over a full minute of six
animated logos when you're an animal
likes a balancing act
narration movies opening skin shop is
basically a ripoff of a Pixar short the
beasts protagonist is an asshole also
and this is God's honest truth in
college I was friends with a guy who was
in a band and that band had a song with
lyrics they went like this someone
kicked the pigeon someone kicked the
pigeon someone kicked a pigeon I swear
to holy Moses I'm not making this up a
cart devoted to selling humans edible
nuts put some nut Nets logo that no
human would ever eat also you devote
your life's work to selling roadside
peanuts and cashews the best you can
come up with is Morrie's nut shop take a
cue from The Simpsons and put away maybe
Saturday enough fever or cashew outside
how about that either that tree's
branches are growing way too close to
the ground or that's the most overgrown
bush I've seen since I discovered my
uncle's stash of play bullies in the
late 70s now that everything off the
everyone pitches in and stands in line
to help store nuts thing from a bug's
life have optimism brethren step up
everyone hearing Liam Neeson voice of
vacuous racoon is like watching Steve
Martin do porn it's just wrong on every
level chicks dig the tales honestly if I
had to do this video in ten seconds I
would just show this scene here that's
how offensive it is creatively keep a
wary watchful eye out for you know yes
him movie goes triple pronoun game and
an obvious effort just to piss me off
every article in this newspaper is
either gibberish or literally this movie
screenplay is he looking through a
camera
old-school quickie lap binoculars
whatever it is it certainly shouldn't
have this level of zoom and follow my I
originally wrote a scene here where I
simply described what just happened
on-screen but even that sounded too
dirty in broast nobody uses the actual
complete storyboard pitch for the film
as an in movie prop nothing to feed the
park for the entire winter really
because I've seen squirrels eat pretty
sure that cart lasts about as long as a
pizza in the dorm room what to get it we
can work out a deal maybe tries to make
the only likeable character the one
voiced by Katherine Heigl animation
director gloves on Sugar Ray that's like
a 30-year old boxing reference at this
point this is movie taking place in the
70s there's just updated boxing
reference first thing is the movie will
never answer this question
the Acorn cart will now start rolling
after its wheel brake is broken even
though everything thus far has presented
this as a level sidewalk
yeah that's level of this movie just
rewrote gravity for a silly chasing gag
Oh settle down there future serial
killer did I miss something
the reason every single character in
this movie needs to be evil even the
Girl Scout no seriously after a brief
sidewalk chase this nut cart fell about
eight feet into a ravine and caught fire
can I tap out here is that possible
Chris can I get a ruling on this I'd
like to walk away right here now and
let's some other sucker finish writing
sins for this Kamil Dicer to see what
he's doing
Kevin submit physics for the nut job
brought to you by the same folks as the
fast movies might as well call it The
Fast and the furriest as these animals
restoring massive amounts of Orville
Redenbacher classic style in this tree
or this movie has no idea how acorns
work and now destroy our only food
Wednesday to be fair you did foolishly
keep all your food for winter inside one
highly flammable tree I'm just saying we
don't convict without a trial this isn't
how we do things
overly political movie about Park
rodents has a point what is also openly
political why does the ground moving
towards a place it wasn't until after
you said that so five minutes after the
explosion
no human activity nothing obvious
mistake wave taken as a vote and no one
complains I'm no expert on raccoons
Rules of Order but surely that can't
count three goes from full burn to a
stump no debris in the same day
magical sticking brick for starting
straight ahead through all these shoes
certainly deserves an honorary degree
from the Prometheus school of running
away from things yes they did just smack
face-first into a brick and mortar
version of the nut shop the cart they
quit that started this whole adventure
because this giant city is actually
super small looting us time for this
rats repeatedly struggle to find a way
inside a big city building suspension of
disbelief ruined
that's a dead squirrel no one in the
history of ever with this many
mousetraps in the rafters I mean the
movie Mouse on a side obviously buddy
thank you much cheese bark jokes the
lazy writers comedy grudge Oh dog would
walk right by a pink squirrel without
noticing or smelling his squirrel last
thing about Moby is mine I'm singable
boobie Sally how tiny is the city also
Oakland whiskey big oak ton what's with
all the oak puns is it just the Acorn
thing because if so then they went to
carrot top workout levels of too far
here this dartboard
Elaine's a dartboard 12 feet off the
ground in the center of a room on a
pillar with no backstop the rat silently
pulls on surly twice instead of simply
saying humans are coming you dip let's
get out of here obvious foreshadowing
cliched we are not a pack of wild
animals literally the opposite of the
truth winter is coming
you movie that came out well after Game
of Thrones and this phrase was well
established in pop culture you all the
ways he's blind he's handicapped in none
of his friends care that's hilarious
right right why are we doing this at
night mole would be great at cinema
since someone remind me why we care
about this heist again do we even know
enough to root for or against it
movie includes two different heights in
this heist movie and neither one has the
decency to actually be interesting
enough cashews to buy yourselves a race
track now maybe this is mobster talk for
dollars but cashews are not that high
price enough and the amount of cashews
it would take to be worth enough to buy
a race track is frankly staggering also
these cashews can stand in for the word
dollars then literally any word camp I'm
gonna shake it down for for Tomatoes the
buy-in for this poker game is 30 I've
put a growth this is my last heist
last heist cliche I hate you moving the
coincidence of the brick shovel and TNT
placement is infuriating to put it
mildly
so you knew what dynamite was and yet
you were still throwing it around with
impunity I kind of think you might be
getting what you deserve here
dynamite doesn't destroy it merely
propels things near it that's squirrel
was trying to blow up the nut strong and
precious doctor that might be the single
biggest leap in film history yep another
sin for the film for this goddamn acorn
logo nut shop having opened in 1892 and
stayed in business this long look in the
background look how huge this city is
and then remember how easily everyone
found each other in this movie after
leaving the park and then if you're like
me you get frustrated and borderline
angry I get to this character arc is too
mature from being a self-centered dick
but more than halfway in and he's still
callously face-planting the only person
that's been nice to him I think we might
be teetering on unredeemable Grayson
surly here's another random bump into a
moment in a film ostensibly taking place
in New York City or some other huge
metropolitan area just hey this person
is now here deal with it this one uh me
Rogan guns a squirrel repeller
here's a shot of a dog in a squirrel
giving CPR to a couple of groundhog
beaver something's and this weird yo how
the animals know CPR oh I need glasses
this movie is basically a dick to the
visually impaired there are punchline to
this movie double entendre intended
movie doesn't know that double entendres
usually reserved for risque or indecent
double meanings unless of course it does
in which case it too serves us in anyway
for making me consider what kind of
mulling has been happening between these
two but it was my but but but but but
but now laughs yes let's bring the head
mobster down to look at the squirrel we
got started and grab me that blood car
so you're going to torture goddamn
squirrel why does the bad guys plan
involve gas tanks and gas tanks
apparently being removed
why were there even gas tanks down in
the peanut vault anyway we got to go to
a tunnel stuff movie gives me another
euphemism for taking my wife to bed
that's how you double entendre this
really is my last job
movie only scratches the surface of what
could have actually been a clever
juxtaposition between the human highest
and the squirrel heist instead leaving
us with an unnecessary background human
story that never pays off or has any
depth the monsters girlfriend who
somehow on the way down here grows a
conscience and lets surly out of his
cage and I mean obviously thank God
because I'm so ready for the end but
spill that's a boat oh joy the green
rats are back somehow tracked this guy
here in a humongous city because we
needed to pad the runtime duh and Liam
Neeson's raccoon shows up right at this
moment as well in case you hadn't yet
realized he was a selfish evil dick
dynomite ex machina yet another movie
that suggests banks keep dozens of bags
filled with coins in their vaults bank
heist plan involves an explosion loud
enough to break through two feet of
concrete and rebar still not be heard by
anyone in the bank
seasoned mob boss use his gun to attempt
to kill rodents that he shouldn't care
about considering no one will be here
tomorrow seriously I had a squirrel in
my house last week who literally open
the door let it run out no bullets
required this guy half-assed closes this
truck door allowing much of the rest of
the movie to take place main villain
betrays people who just bought his lies
hook line and sinker because reasons not
to go all Monty Python on you but
pigeons cannot carry squirrels
it's simple weight ratios and no not
even the African pigeons I really hate
this movie this all the cops are in the
doughnut shop gag is super fresh and
hilarious
Grayson survives this well someone saw
speed well is he because all I've seen
is a greedy selfish rude son of a sound
who may have felt guilty a few times but
still hasn't done anything that could be
considered solely heroic even this
vehicle is full of the nutsy ones I
don't the not immediately obvious that
Berman Neeson here is completely evil by
this point how many times does a leader
have to screw over before you realize he
isn't who he says he is well really
dragging that donut joke all the way to
the hostage standoff huh and did he pour
himself that mug of coffee after he got
their villain who won't die cliche not
that I'm sure how anyone would die in
this world anyway darling ah suicide in
an animated kids movie also what why
would he let go and even the game
weren't in danger there's nothing to
lose by trying to hold on
self-sacrifice only works when there's
actually something to sacrifice for
otherwise it's just self stupidity also
yeah he'll be fine I'm sure because this
movie is simple look still scar me once
shame on you
transportation by floating rocks I know
we through physics out the window a long
time ago but the idea that a wheel at
that speed could launch anything to any
height is worth at least two more sins
minimum heart beat a dimpled way firstly
the king dimple we'd also glad they
resolved that plotline they barely made
reference to this entire movie come with
me so precious knew that surly had
washed up here and instead of
checking to see if he was alive or do
any kind of rescue he sauntered over to
the park to gently tell buddy to come
look at his dead friend's body
no precious bad dog surly Jesus is
himself back into this movie no way and
he you may have forgotten the things
he's done but cinemasins never forgets
[Music]
fully animated Gangnam style credits
consider your sins double
I will find you
and I will kill you where's Boone cousin
rhythmic Street breath I don't find us
this little part of a job I hate I'm
just a squirrel trying to get a nut
somebody jump on the dance floor so what
I'm going to think exit Felix and stand
there with a not so bright look on your
face winter is coming we don't work with
surly we won't survive did grace